forget
everything you know about the united
states of america
it's not united anymore but
divided into several independent nations
no this isn't the result of a divisive
election
this is what america's borders would
look like
if it were never stumbled upon by
christopher columbus
what would this mean for the indigenous
populations that
already lived there could they have
become
a global superpower and
how would this impact the development of
europe
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if columbus never discovered america
in school most of us are taught that
christopher columbus discovered
america in 1492 but
in reality there's evidence that the
vikings
and the polynesians were there hundreds
of years before
and most importantly we can't really say
he
discovered anything when there were
already millions of people living there
but columbus arriving in america did
spark
massive amounts of exploration and
colonization that
led to the world as we know it so
if he never arrived in america
would colonization still have happened
before we go too far down the alternate
history route
let's set a few real historical facts
straight
first off before columbus arrived the
americas
were not just sparsely populated wild
lands with
tribes wandering through them instead
there were actually more people in the
americas
living in complex and highly organized
societies
than there were in europe all of the
communities had
rich and mature cultures and established
languages
there's even some evidence that
indigenous populations of north and
south america
occupied the region for about 000
years before columbus arrived since time
immemorial they had diversified so
greatly in terms of culture that they
spoke approximately 300 different
languages
but that all changed when columbus and
the european colonizers arrived
a study from england's university
college london found
that the european colonization of the
americas
indirectly contributed to the deaths of
56 million people by the year sixteen
hundred
the study attributes the deaths to
factors including
introduced disease such as smallpox and
measles
as well as warfare and societal collapse
if the americas had never been colonized
by the europeans
not only would many lives have been
saved but also various cultures
and languages through colonization
the indigenous populations were labeled
as indians
they were enslaved and they were forced
to abandon their own cultures
and convert to christianity
if it weren't for this oppression the
indigenous nations
would have continued to develop and
progress
modern-day california would be the most
densely populated region but
the entire continent would be divided
into different nations
much like europe and asia smaller tribes
would get swallowed up by larger ones
and
borders would continue to change
throughout history
but one group that may have emerged as a
dominant culture over the others
would be the iroquois they were known as
one of the strongest nations
due to their successful agricultural
practices
and their ability to invade other
nations
if columbus hadn't brought colonization
over to the americas
then the iroquois would probably have
continued to grow their nation
and surround much of the great lakes
area and the mississippi river
and our geographical borders wouldn't be
the only things that would look
different in this
alternate timeline our diets would too
wheat would not have been a staple in
the american continents
as this is something introduced from
europe
and american foods like corn tomatoes
and potatoes
would not have been introduced to the
europeans
[Music]
but in all honesty even if christopher
columbus didn't sail the ocean blue
america would likely have still been
invaded
the age of exploration beginning in 1450
had
many nations looking for new lands to
conquer and
goods to exploit so eventually
someone would have stumbled upon it
nowadays the only new worlds to be
discovered are in
outer space if we find one we can live
on
let's take a lesson from our history
here on earth
if someone already lives there let's
just leave them alone
but that's a story for another
what if